Traduttore: Karen Bradberry
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io mi occupo di religioni,
pur non avendo avuto
una formazione confessionale
e neppure di tipo religioso,
però, appunto, me ne occupo
soprattutto per un interesse personale,
ma soprattutto perché ho lavorato,
ci sto lavorando da molto tempo
in questa trasmissione radiofonica.
Naturalmente è sempre un po' imbarazzante,
lo ho notato anche in questi giorni,
anche ieri sera e poi stamattina,
parlare di religioni
ad un contesto vasto e composito,
perché sicuramente tra voi
c'è chi ha una fede certa,
che io sicuramente non vorrei ferire,
e c'è chi invece ritiene le religioni
una sopravvivenza del passato,
con delle buone ragioni
che non vorrei contraddire;
e c'è chi ritiene che le religioni
siano, così, un orpello inutile,
è inutile interessarsene,
sono capaci di portare
soltanto violenza e distruzione;
e anche questo ha un suo senso.
Poi, parlare di religioni è complicato
perché dentro questa categoria
facciamo confluire
una serie sterminata
di storie e di esperienze.
Ci sono le religioni che hanno un dio
e quelle senza dio,
le religioni politeiste
e quelle monoteiste,
ci sono religioni scomparse, e nuove fedi.
Religioni intese come fatto privato,
e invece religioni intese
come elemento identitario.
Oltre a ciò,
ogni religione si è articolata
in uno spazio infinito di scuole,
sette, chiese, derivazioni ecc. ecc.
E poi, ancora: quando diciamo religioni,
di che cosa parliamo?
Parliamo dei leader, come si dice,
delle grandi religioni,
oppure parliamo, non lo so,
di un prete di strada,
o di un monaco ritirato nel suo eremo,
o invece di un cardinale di curia,
di un fondamentalista fanatico?
Ecco, sono tante le cose
che si possono dire.
Allora, per questo io vorrei proporvi
due percorsi questa sera,
perché ci si potrebbe smarrire,
come di fronte ad ogni altra
esperienza dell'umano,
pensate all'esperienza scientifica,
la letteratura, la società, la storia.
Però, appunto, il fatto religioso
appartiene al tempo dell'umano
e dunque noi possiamo rinvenire
qualche traccia, almeno,
delle antiche sapienze,
che possa avere un senso, forse,
per l'umanità tutta intera.
Il primo passo di questo percorso
parte da un testo antichissimo, Iveda,
una raccolta di testi dei popoli ari,
stanziati nell'India settentrionale,
composto fra il 1500
avanti la nostra era
e l'anno 1000,
che compendiano, appunto, vari saperi.
Sentite, vi voglio leggere
soltanto un frammento.
"In principio non vi era essere,
né non essere;
non vi era l'aria,
né ancora il cielo al di là.
Che cosa lo avvolgeva?
Dove, chi proteggeva?
C'era l'acqua, insondabile e profonda?
In quel momento,
non vi era né la morte né l'immortalità,
non vi era segno della notte,
né del giorno.
Da dove questa creazione sia sorta,
se egli l'ha fondata oppure no,
colui che la sorveglia
nel più alto nei cieli,
lui solo lo sa.
O forse, non lo sa".
Ecco, allora, vedete,
così comincia il pensare dell'uomo:
con l'interrogazione, con lo stupore.
[Con] il desiderio di sapere,
ma anche la coscienza di non sapere.
Io trovo che vi sia qualcosa di grandioso,
in questo interrogare
e in questo dubitare.
Ciò che ha mosso, ha dato origine
alle grandi tradizioni religiose,
è quello che ha mosso e ha dato origine
a tutto il sapere dell'umanità,
fino ad arrivare alla ricerca spaziale
o al web, al wireless e così via:
la scienza, la raffigurazione artistica,
la scrittura, la misurazione
della creatura umana dentro l'universo.
Allora io credo che dovremmo tener care
le domande delle antiche sapienze,
perché sono le stesse che animano
ogni indagine dell'essere umano,
anche nel nostro tempo.
Dovremmo tener caro quel loro affacciarsi
sulla scena del mondo
con, avete sentito,
lo stupore di essere vivi,
lo stupore di essere
qualcosa in questa vita.
Queste domande allora vanno custodite:
ma non fossilizzate, come spesso
le istituzioni religiose hanno fatto,
non codificate, ma spalancate,
tenendo aperta la molteplicità
delle risposte.
Scegliendo, certamente:
ciascuno di noi sceglierà una strada,
perché non le può percorrere tutte;
però sapendo che invece
ce ne sono tante altre.
Allora solo così si può far circolare
aria, vento, respiro
dentro quelle domande,
senza soffocarle nel chiuso asfittico
di sacrestie, di sette, di estremismi.
Usando intelligenza, usando critica.
Mettendo in crisi ogni volta
le idee troppo compiute,
Aprendo orizzonti nuovi e nuove libertà.
Pensate come sarebbe umiliante -
come è, talvolta, umiliante,
nella storia degli esseri umani,
ridurre la propria libertà, ridurre anche
il libero usare del pensiero,
in nome di un credo,
di una convinzione, di un principio.
Questo è accaduto molto spesso
nella storia delle religioni,
ma il fondamento delle fedi
sta in altro, sta nell'aperto.
L'altro percorso che vi voglio proporre
muove invece da un diverso input,
da una diversa spinta
che ha contribuito a creare, forgiare,
plasmare, far nascere le religioni:
quello di alleviare le sofferenze
degli essere umani,
quello di dare un senso al dolore,
di estinguerlo dove sia possibile,
quello di contenere
le forze distruttive che ci abitano,
quello di provare a fare comunità,
a fare città, a fare società,
a costruire convivenza.
È vero che, nella storia,
le tradizioni religiose
hanno provocato guerre,
sostenuto violenze, incoraggiato soprusi,
fomentato distruzioni;
ma questo è accaduto e accade sempre,
continua ad accadere,
quando si smette di interrogare,
quando si crede di possedere la verità
invece di continuare a cercarla.
Quando invece di un Dio,
inafferrabile, inconoscibile,
costruiamo con le nostre mani
una serie infinita di idoli,
una serie infinita di vitelli d'oro.
Ed è bene ricordare che è idolatra
non soltanto chi si costruisce
una falsa immagine di Dio,
ma che le nostre vite
sono abitate da idoli:
pensiamo all'idolo
del denaro, del possesso,
l'idolo che ciascuno di noi è a se stesso.
"Signore, liberami da me stesso"
dice una poesia di Fernando Pessoa.
Allora, come fare in modo
che Dio non sia un idolo?
"Il volto di Dio non si può vedere",
questo è scritto nei libri della Torah;
e dunque "non si può vedere"
vuol dire che non ci è dato immaginarlo,
non ci è dato farne feticci, statuette,
presumere di conoscerlo,
illudersi che sia dalla nostra parte.
Questo guardate che è un comandamento,
è il secondo dei comandamenti,
dopo "Io sono il Signore",
che vuol dire che esiste un Dio -
se esiste naturalmente -
ma unico per tutta l'umanità.
Poi vi è il terzo comandamento:
non pronunciare falsamente il suo nome.
E cioè, a rigore,
siccome nulla di vero
l'uomo può sapere su Dio,
meglio non proferire mai il suo nome.
E difatti, il nome di Dio è inconoscibile,
è contenuto in quattro
lettere impronunciabili;
e pensate che anche
nella tradizione islamica
ci sono 99 nomi di Dio:
ma non sono dei sostantivi, sono
degli aggettivi, cioè degli attributi;
poi c'è un centesimo nome
che nessuno conosce,
perché lo conosce solo Dio.
Ecco, capiamo bene
che cosa significa questo,
un Dio il cui volto non si può vedere,
il cui nome non si può pronunciare
è un Dio dai larghi confini,
è un Dio che abita
nelle profondità dei cuori umani,
ma anche negli abissi degli universi.
Tuttavia, di quel Dio,
o di quel qualcosa a cui noi
abbiamo dato e diamo il nome di Dio,
vi è traccia nella ricerca
degli esseri umani.
Vi è una traccia scritta
nella storia dell'uomo,
nelle strategie per costruire
una città degli uomini,
dove i conflitti possono essere
mediati, elaborati,
dove le libertà degli uni
entrino in dialettica
con le libertà degli altri.
Dove sia possibile una vita di umanità,
e non di bestialità.
Un altro testo, un'altra affermazione:
"Dio nessuno Lo ha mai visto".
Questo è scritto nel Prologo
del Vangelo di Giovanni
e in una delle lettere di Giovanni
si dice, ancora,
"Nessuno ha mai visto Dio".
E si aggiunge, subito dopo:
"Se ci amiamo gli uni gli altri,
Dio rimane in noi,
e l'amore di Lui è perfetto in noi"
Allora cerchiamo di capire,
anche qui, questa implicazione.
"Nessuno ha mai visto Dio".
"Se ci amiamo gli uni gli altri,
Dio rimane in noi,
e l'amore di Lui è perfetto in noi".
Allora ciò che conta
non è l'immaginarsi che cosa sia Dio,
ma quella parola
che viene definita con "amore".
L'amore che sappiamo scambiarci,
l'amore che sappiamo costruire,
l'amore che sappiamo realizzare.
Però, certamente, l'amore:
che parola imbarazzante,
che parola abusata, svilita.
Qualche volta, a me personalmente,
viene la nausea a sentir parlare
di questo amore,
una parola astratta, più pronunciata
che non realizzata nei fatti.
E poi, anche,
non ci facciamo illusioni
sulla creatura umana:
sappiamo di cosa siamo fatti,
sappiamo che siamo un impasto
di tensioni, di amore e di odio.
Mi piace ricordare le parole di Pascal:
"Quale chimera è l'uomo,
quale novità, quel mostro, quale caos,
quale soggetto di contraddizione,
quale prodigio,
giudice di tutte le cose
e stupido verme della terra;
depositario della verità
e cloaca di incertezza ed errore;
gloria e rifiuto dell'Universo".
Ma l'essere umano è anche capace
di quell'amore,
di quell'attenzione all'altro,
di quella cura,
di quella responsabilità per l'altro
che lo rende umano,
ed è questo che conta.
È questo che conta
anche per il Dio della Bibbia,
che dice, per bocca dei suoi profeti,
"Io detesto le vostre feste,
non gradisco le vostre
riunioni in mio nome;
anche se voi mi offrite olocausti
a me non interessano,
non voglio le vostre vittime grasse;
lontano da me il frastuono
dei vostri canti,
il suono delle vostre arpe.
Piuttosto, scorra come acqua
il diritto e la giustizia,
come un torrente perenne".
La rettitudine, la giustizia,
il non nuocere, il costruire cose buone:
è della vita umana
che ci parlano le Scritture.
Per questo credo vadano lette,
studiate, comprese,
interpretate in un commento
che non ha mai fine,
perché cresce con noi,
con ciascun essere umano che le accosti,
così come noi cresciamo
con la frequentazione di quelle parole
e di quella continua interpretazione.
E ci accorgeremmo, allora,
come vi sia un filo che unisce
le Scritture e le tradizioni
di tutti i tempi e di tutti i luoghi:
ed è, appunto, l'attenzione all'umano.
Lo avete presente, nei Vangeli sinottici,
quando qualcuno chiede a Gesù
qual è il comandamento più grande,
lui mette insieme, nel racconto,
due proposizioni dell'Antico Testamento,
"Ama il Dio unico"
e "Ama il prossimo tuo
perché egli è te stesso".
Dice che questo è un unico comandamento.
Allora questo significa che se si ama Dio,
se qualcuno dice di amare Dio
non è vero, se non ama
anche il suo prossimo;
e se ama il suo prossimo,
questo è sufficiente per amare anche Dio.
Se noi allarghiamo lo sguardo
al di fuori delle scritture
giudaiche e cristiane,
vediamo che in tutte,
ma davvero in tutte -
in tutte le sapienze,
non solo le scritture -
troviamo delle affermazioni analoghe,
nei grandi poemi indiani
e nei discorsi del Buddha,
nei pensieri di Confucio,
nelle massime del Tao,
nel giainismo, nello zoroastrismo,
nei detti del profeta Muhammad,
nella sapienza latina.
Fino ad arrivare alla
Dichiarazione dei Diritti dell'Uomo:
"Tutti gli uomini dotati
di ragione, di coscienza,
devono assumere responsabilità,
in spirito di solidarietà,
nei confronti di ciascuno e di tutti:
famiglie, comunità, nazioni e religioni".
Ciò che tu non vuoi che ti venga fatto,
non farlo a nessun altro.
Questo, in definitiva,
il programma di ogni religione;
e non mi sembra un piccolo programma,
non mi sembra trascurabile.
Per questo credo che valga la pena, oggi,
interrogare ancora i tracciati delle fedi.
Non credo che ci dobbiamo
sbarazzare delle religioni;
credo che ci dobbiamo sbarazzare
di una lettura ottusa delle religioni,
di un ascolto opaco,
con "un orecchio ostruito di ortica",
come dice la poetessa Nelly Sachs.
Ecco: credo che ciascuno
dovrebbe sentirsi responsabile
del patrimonio di tradizione
che ha ricevuto in eredità;
anzi, ognuno di noi
dovrebbe farsi tradizione
ed assumersi il rischio
di una interpretazione dei testi antichi
che sia all'altezza del nostro presente.
Con rispetto, ma senza sudditanza;
con cognizione, ma anche con audacia.
Rigenerare, rianimare le parole antiche,
rileggerle alla luce del presente.
Voglio chiudere leggendovi
un versetto del Deuteronomio, che dice:
"Questo comando che oggi ti do
non è troppo alto per te,
né troppo lontano da te;
non è nel cielo, cosicché tu possa dire
"Come faccio a raggiungerlo";
non è al di là del mare,
cosicché tu possa dire
'Ma chi me lo potrà mai portare vicino'.
Anzi, questa parola è molto vicina a te,
è nella tua bocca e nel tuo cuore
perché tu la metta in pratica.
Vedi, io oggi pongo di fronte a te
la vita e il bene, la morte e il male,
la benedizione e la maledizione:
scegli dunque la vita,
perché tu possa vivere,
tu e la tua discendenza".
Ecco, si tratta, anche per noi, credo,
di scegliere una vita
o almeno di provarci.
Spero di avere spostato,
almeno un poco, le vostre convinzioni.
Grazie.
(Applausi)